buckle up kids huh because we've got an
artbook coming it is cooler than you
think
next week Tuesday November 6 Marvel's
Avengers infinity war the art of the
movie will be released it's awesome it's
the whole book of concept art you got
character art production photos really
cool stuff but I'm excited to check this
out and see all the stuff that they were
maybe going to put do differently in the
movie like you can see here you got cap
with slightly shorter hair I also got
like a hip scarf oh boy you know what
it's a little nippy outside to the fall
weather it's a balmy 60 degrees he's
feeling an espresso heater you're
bragging spice cap there what did you I
what are you most excited about when it
comes to this book because we're gonna
be getting a lot more details I'm
excited to see alternate costumes I
always love the guardians books in
particular because I like the way the
James can the arc team would try to
realize these cosmic characters in
different ways like rocket I always had
cool designs but I'm actually really
excited to see what the other ways they
thought of bringing like the Infinity
Gauntlet to life like what L there does
not because it has like scarabs oh yeah
there's all kinds of ancient runes on it
you know when you watch infinity war one
of things I loved about it is the
production design like they come
actually came with some very clever ways
to depict the action which you don't
always see in these big climactic
battles we've seen movies where they
don't do well infinity war really did
pull it off and these battles they have
like this epic scale to them that feels
unique to the characters like that
one-on-one duel between Doctor Strange
and Thanos they're just firing spells at
each other oh it feels like honestly an
even better version of the Dumbledore
Voldemort fight in order the Phoenix
where they had the elements they had the
earth wind water fire here they were
kind of doing that he was firing like a
mirror dimension that turned into a
black hole it honestly felt like Marvel
said to them the sky's the limit when it
comes to our visual effects budget
whatever crazy crap you want these
characters to do we can pull it off and
they did like we got iron spider in this
concept art you can see Iron Man has
this like lobster claw grip maybe to
wrap around the Infinity Gauntlet and
yank it off and you got nebula there you
got mantis as well like there's a lot of
cool things and you get you get to see
right off the bat you see star-lord
jumping on the little there's a couple
different names from there cuz of
principies the frisbees the magic
his technical term I remember in one of
the pitches the Russos were like oh we
didn't want calf to show up until the
last second of this movie I was like and
that would have been awesome what do you
how did you picture that happening I
hope that's in the book as well yeah I
think there were fit I think the idea
was they wanted him his entrance to be
like Thor's entrance how that was big
like applause momen infinity Wars for
screening he still gets a pretty cool
entrance he gets very okay ominous music
there was another image from the concept
art that I saw that had like dr. strange
putting like his finger on the nose like
right and like his third eye area and
putting Dennis in a trance and I don't
know if though they're gonna doctor
stranger that instead of mantis and
that's how he's gonna be put in that
kind of state of paralysis the hypnotism
but it also made me think like oh well
as part of dr. Strange's plan at some
point to like read Thanos his thoughts
and maybe that's how they were gonna
discover what he did to Gamora there's
just a lot of because it reminded me a
lot of when the ancient one does that
too strange was like open your eye and
in doctor training zips through the
magical mystery tour of the different
realities maybe the plan was to do that
with Thanos just to melt his brain
yeah we think a psychedelic trip I think
I think they knows won't be able to
control that I don't think he would yeah
yeah but we've been a struggle right he
just got the reality stone maybe that's
how he would have to like use that to
like grab on at the edge of a reality
and like fly back in because there was
also concept art of like Stannis having
to fight in some like wormhole portal
looking thing like it's real trippy
stuff and I didn't know if that was just
part of like wind dr. strange through
the mirror dimension at him and then he
turned into a black hole and fired it
back at him we're gonna see some version
of that and that's what that art was
depicting as opposed to them fighting
through different Rick and Morty style
dimension there yeah which way I would
have been fine but I would have that's
what I wanted the whole movie but no I
think most of all I'm excited to see we
didn't know that you bring it up the
doctor strange magic I want to see how
they interpret that I want to see what
the Russos do with that because or what
they wanted to do with that because
they're they just have such a good knack
at nailing these characters I'm like
well how else did you see this character
coming to life in your movie he was
crazy as like dr. strange has been the
most like beneficial gift giver in terms
of like different theories the most
unopened book I would say like
movie came not everyone was that I'd
like the movie but not everyone holds
Doctor Strange like their Marvel top
five I would say yeah it's like oh he's
here he introduced the time stone were
good but like dr. Strange's abilities
are so fascinated and the way he looks
at the universe and the cosmos is unlike
any other character so this whole idea
of like dr. Strange's plan has given us
like endless things to talk about on
this channel thank you yeah thanks dr.
strange
so he's the character I want to explore
the most or at least you know the whole
idea of the mystic arts in Avengers 4 I
think there's a lot of untapped
potential oh yeah also alternate looks
for Bucky's arm would be really down to
see what he got the new yeah we got the
blue and the gold not bad not bad but I
would like to see some alternatives also
when we get into that solo series
alright seeing if like what if he's got
interchangeable arms why not well let us
know what you think about this art book
or what other details did you spot in
the comments below
yeah there's we got some time before we
will get an Avengers 4 trailer by the
end of this year but we got some reading
to do before that happens it sounds like
thanks everybody thank you